[Musique]
nous sommes en 1956 dans les Laurentides
des agents du ministère de la chasse et
de la pêche nourrissent les chevreuils
qui sont menacés par les loups ils sont
encore peu nombreux à cette époque il
travaille dans des conditions parfois
difficiles ils sont aussi mal rémunérés
mais ce sont le plus souvent des
passionnés de la nature énergie des
grands explorateurs qui ne sont précédés
le salimentait pas seulement dans un
idéal un peu comme ces jeunes qui sont
allés en expédition pour découvrir le
Nord québécois et qui ont rencontré
cette pionnière la première femme de la
province être nommée garde de chasse
dans les années 30 mode
voulait protéger les castors et aider
les autochtones
ils ont beaucoup plus ils ont plus
d'argent ils n'ont plus de nourriture
des possibilités nutritives de ce
territoire du moins pendant les longs
mois à cette époque on comprenait qu'il
fallait gérer cette ressource mais on
réalisait aussi qu'il fallait donner de
meilleures conditions et une meilleure
formation à ceux qui allaient faire ce
travail sur le terrain avoir
l'illégalement tuer un mortier
à l'école des garde-chasse de Québec une
nouvelle formation est donnée on insiste
entre autres sur l'importance de mettre
fin au braconnage en 1970 le
gouvernement adopte la Loi de la
conservation de la faune la désignation
des garde-chasse et des gardes de pêche
et modifiées ils deviennent des agents
de conservation de la faune c'était un
petit peu pour redorer l'image des
agents du service puis aussi un peu pour
mieux exprimer la polyvalence de l'agent
de conservation
la convention de la BB James est signée
en 1975 et accords
sur les décisions touchant la protection
de leur environnement le gouvernement en
profite par la suite pour offrir une
première formation au cri nascapi et
inouïe du Nouveau-Québec
devient le premier agent autochtone
depuis hier 1er avril les droits
exclusifs de chasser de pêche dans les
clubs privés sont abolis le gouvernement
abolit les 1200 clubs privés de chasse
et de pêche toute une révolution une
mesure bien accueillie par les citoyens
sont fiers de savoir un peu moins par
les partisans des clubs privés la
formule n'est pas rodée on ne croit pas
qu'il puisse mettre en place des
structures valable qui pour assurer le
contrôle de l'exploitation de forêt le
gouvernement du Québec adopte en 1977
la loi sur les parcs ce qui lui donne le
pouvoir d'établir des parcs de
conservation et de récréation ou
l'exploitation des ressources est
interdite contrairement à ce qui
existait avant le gouvernement du Québec
ne peut pas de son propre chef décidé de
permettre l'exploitation minière ou
exploitation pharmacienne à l'intérieur
des parcs reconnus il va devoir aller en
audience publique je pense que c'est
fondamental puis je pense que c'est
c'est presque historique ça à faire là
évidemment c'est historique à l'automne
les parcs du Québec s'ouvrent à nous de
façon spectaculaire et plus proche de
nous la création en 1985 de la Société
des établissements de plein air du
Québec la Sépaq qui est un élément
important de la protection de notre
biodiversité
Jacques bissonner Radio-Canada Montréal
[Musique]